you play a grown-up Dan Torrance you
heavily influenced by his father so my
first question to you is what did you
take from Danny Lloyd and Jack
Nicholson's performances for your role I
mean I took a lot more from Jack really
because I think when you're playing the
adult version of a smut of a young child
like that there's only so much you can
get from their performance and of course
he was so brilliant but he was very he's
like a blank canvas wasn't he and
Kubrick was able to use his performance
beautifully but it was very sort of
withheld and I so I got much more by
watching Jack and I felt very much that
you know we are know through experience
that we can't help but have a lot of our
fathers in us as men so I listened to a
lot of Jack on set I listened to his I
would just have like interviews with him
or just to listen to the cadence of his
voice because I feel like we all sound
like our dad like if you met my dad now
you wouldn't you would know would you
recognise my voice from his you came
from so I wanted to try and do that with
this so I tried to sound a little bit
like Jack or at least have a flavor of
him in my voice when I when I'm playing
Danny and then that sort of that's sort
of where he's my dad so I just I just
was thinking of Jack Nicholson be my dad
and how cool and strange that would be
and then I left it because I feel like
the the marshes and the the clever the
satisfying elements I hope for the
audience that Mike Flanagan is put into
the movie where we recognise scenes or
moments from The Shining in our film
it's best for me not to really be
thinking about because I'm on the inside
of it and no that would be like thinking
on the outside hey did you talk to Jack
Nicholson I didn't
I must have met I I know I've seen him
somewhere
you know at wards or something and when
I started off I know I've been in his
company somewhere but I've never I never
met him or spoken to him which is a
shame well I thought you did is you
nailed a but no good I'm curious what is
the scariest part of the shining for you
because I know you watched it as a team
yes
so scary I don't really watch it but it
came out because I just knew it had this
had
reputation of being the most terrifying
film ever made so I was I was too
sensitive to watch that kind of thing
when I was a kid so I ended up watching
it in my 20s probably for the first time
and I watched it alone
because I thought like well if you're
gonna do it you should do it properly I
watched at night alone and I think it's
funny when he meets and I kind of
remember as Lloyd or Floyd the barman
Lloyd it's when he meets Lloyd
Floyd wouldn't be so frightening Oh
scary
Lloyd what he meets Lloyd in the bar I
think that's there's just like when it
when there's suddenly he's there and
Jack has that conversation with him
that's probably that's when I started
hiding behind the sofa Mike I'm so
excited to talk to you about this about
I mean first off my thought is how did
you pull this off you had the unique job
of making a sequel to Kubrick shining
and to King shining so how did you walk
that tightrope with with nothing but
kind of intense anxiety really and I
don't know if we pulled it off I won't
know if we if we really pulled it off
until it's out there in the world but
yeah I mean you're you're kind of
zeroing in on what has felt like this
intense ulcer that's been eating away at
me for the last two years yeah I grew up
worshiping Stephen King I saw The
Shining when I was very very young way
too young to see the shining I've never
had a film that was kind of more
formative and influential on me and I've
never had you know another author who
I've idolized this much so so I don't
know kind of how how we went about
pulling it all together short of it was
it was a thousand questions every day
that kind of just felt like we were we
were always on on a tight rope trying to
kind of pull pull those two sources
together well congratulations what an
accomplishment and I'm sure it was
easier because you are such a super fan
but now I'm curious what is the scariest
part of the shining for you of the film
yeah or the book and so the scariest
scene in the movie for me it's it's the
Grady twins the first time not the first
time you see them which is in the game
room but the first time he sees them
after
Hotel is abandoned when he comes around
the corner on the big wheel
that knocked me out when I was when I
was a kid the the image of them that
their stillness the symmetry of it was
terrifying I think as I've gotten older
the scariest scene of the film to me
is the conversation in the bathroom
between Jack Torrance and and Delbert
Grady so terrified yeah the the
insidious kind of casual suggestion of
the scene to me is just just chilling
and you creating it's so good I have to
ask because our fans are huge fans of
haunting of Hill House I wanted to ask
you about black man or what can you tell
me about it and how will it be different
from the first series well you know it's
it's all based on the writing of Henry
James this time which is really cool and
the turn of the screw
yes which has been adapted actually so
many times that it's it's kind of
impossible to find a straight adaptation
that hasn't already been done and done
perfectly I think in the case of Jack
Clayton's the innocence you know so the
really cool surprise for everybody with
this season I think is that we're not
limited just to that source we have
access to all of Henry James's ghost
stories that haven't been adapted to
death and so it really is kind of
turning into a very cool greatest hits
album of all of the Henry James ghost
stories and turn of the screw is just
kind of the most famous of them there's
a bunch of other really wonderful
material that's all kind of being
braided together for this that I think
is really cool well I can't wait to see
what you do with that I love your
aesthetic so much especially in this
movie too and I feel like color is very
important to you so how do you develop
your aesthetic and what is the color
blue mean in this film because
everywhere the cool Blues have been only
increasing kind of in in my work over
the last few years I just love I love
the way it looks is really the not
nearly as an intellectual answer as you
want I'm sure but now a color is
critical I think Stanley Kubrick
understood that you know in a way that
was so far ahead of his time you know
for me and for Michael Fleeman yaari
who's been my DP now
since oculus you know kind of sense from
the beginning you know we're always
trying to find a palette that not only
kind of starts to connect that you know
connects kind of all of the work we do
together into the same family but that
is also kind of pulling and pulling away
the warmth from the story visually and a
story like this in particular when we
used colors on the warm side of the
spectrum when we did get into our reds
and our oranges
I wanted it to land with with a lot of
impact and that meant that when we're
out in the world before that pulling
that warmth out letting everything get
kind of cobalt you know get really kind
of cold yeah you know I thought that
could be a really really wonderful way
to approach it
congratulations on the film Rebecca I
was so excited to see you in it and when
I was reading about the fact that you
hate scary stuff and then thought about
the role that you played in this film I
was like what was the biggest cognitive
therapy that's what it is you know
challenge your fear it is very different
I was gonna say it's very different
shooting something and being a part of
something than watching it because I am
in utter control of of what I'm doing
and I know the outcome the idea of
sitting in a cinema and things jump out
is just it's just not fun I just get but
you know I was talking about it I hate
it so much well here's the thing there's
the scene there's a murder scene in this
film that is the most traumatizing yeah
that another actor plays and I'm sure
that was I mean what was that like
pretty intense and unexpected I didn't
think I would have such a acute reaction
to the acting to the point that I
actually needed to shape up because I
would have ruined the scene and then I I
broke down a little bit after and turned
around and script supervisor wasn't
floods and tears one of the actors of my
clan and doesn't matter who had a memory
from something that happened so that
person walked off I mean it was it was
crazy and then we all had pizza that's
kind of how it works you typical Friday
night but
but but the person who was who was
creating this emotion sat up when I was
done and literally went can I serve
something drink thanks I'm great thanks
we were going such an incredible
performance for me that was the scariest
part of the film but I'm curious to know
what is the scariest part of the shining
the film for you I oh gosh
yeah but there are so many bits and I
always want to be smiled I get very
affected by the sound effects of things
obviously when things jump out but
that's a simple answer for me I I find
the cycling the tricycle of him going
down the corridor we know what's to
expect and we don't want him to stop by
the bloody door and yet he does it but
it's the carpet to the wood and you know
that Mike actually as the geek he is he
built they had they built a grown-up
version of it and we all got to do it
we're literally queued up we did the
whole site bicycle on the carpet I
really loved that he made a big
incredible and then the competition was
on who did the quickest obviously you
yes sure
no I think Mike with pizza in one hand
our fans over at Rotten Tomatoes are
huge fans of doom you could tell me
I play the the mother the protector the
benaderet it's an incredible role it's
what is what is wonderful is Denny you
know if he is together with the writers
creating something that works today
because the book that was written by
Frank Herbert back in the day wasn't as
me - ish as we would have hoped we have
learnt better so I'm kind of a part of a
change for this character an empowerment
over
but yes there was lots to learn and
incredible actors to work with action
your chemistry with um aggregor is so
good in the movie so I want to know what
was it like working with him and I want
to know about the first time you guys
met well the first time we met was
actually in the reading room in audition
I was extremely nervous I was twitching
all over the place actually told him
when we were shooting like a true not
scene I told him that I was switching
all over the place I don't know if he
saw but my leg was doing this oh that
was the first time we met and I think it
was kind of funny I was acting weird
twitching but we had a lot of fun
reading um I think because we grew a
friendship off set we were able to
connect Abra and Dan better and I'm
really happy I got to work with him he's
such an amazing person yeah what was he
like working with onset when you guys
were in character fascinating I mean
it's so cool just to watch him switch
from mr. you and to Dan yeah what word
like the big key differences
well one Jackson - Dan's more dark than
mr. Ewan and I thought that was kind of
cool that was wacky but it was cool yeah
I like that he you know this was your
first movie and you ends an actor that's
been around for a while and Abra has
uncle Dan as a mentor so I felt like
there was some sort of like similar
dynamic oh yeah mr. I see mr. you and a
lot of my mentor date and I think that's
how we relate to Dan and Abra know you
well you killed it think I read that
your mom took you to see the shiny yes
my mom and dad Oh so what was that like
and what is the scariest part of the
shining for you
well these spirits the spirits are
horrible and also the title cards that I
found that so funny yes I was in the
movie theater the sound is surrounding
you you're getting weird vibes and then
bang there's Tuesday that scared me
I don't know why what a good that's so
funny that's interesting though a title
card what was the scariest part of
filming on set because you do some real
scary stuff in this book it was mostly
fun um but I think the scariest ones
were with the spirits in the Overlook
mm-hmm with miss Massey when she had all
her teeth done and
a whole suit I really wanted to get sick
it was gross but as a peace treaty well
I don't I won't scare you if you don't
scare me we did the Macarena kind of to
smother my extreme fear yeah like in
costume yeah I walked in during
rehearsal and I went ahhh so in between
takes we did the Macarena to like not
freak you out yes whose idea was that
was that Mike's mine oh that's really
cool well we feel like working with Mike
Flanagan he's amazing the world does not
deserve Mike Flanagan he's absolutely
he's so talented and he gave us so much
creative freedom I'm so grateful for
that because not a lot of Directors give
you that and he actually called me in
mr. Ewan in for a meeting about her
characters and we talked about them and
he wanted to know if we wanted to add
anything which was super sweet and what
did you say did you add anything Abra I
really just asked him about average
character and when he kind of saw her
but the things that lived there
they come back
[Music]
[Music]